-I'm Steve Higgins,
and we're about to play
a game called Phone Booth, and
our first player of the evening
is the host
of "The Tonight Show",
Mr. Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheering ]
And Jimmy's opponent is a judge
on "America's Got Talent"
and the star of the new show,
"L.A.'s Finest",
it's Gabrielle Union!
[ Cheering ]
The rules of this game
are very simple.
I'll be asking of you
trivia questions,
and if you get a wrong answer, a
stranger from our mystery bench
gets shoved into your phone
booth.
Simple as that.
First question is for Jimmy.
[ Buttons clicking ]
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello?
-Jimmy.
-Yes.
-If you combine
the Jonas Brothers
and the Hemsworth brothers,
how many brothers do you have?
Jonas Brothers, Hemsworth --
-Plus Hemsworths?
-Yes.
-I know there's three Jonas
plus the bonus Jonas.
Four Jonas brothers, and, um,
Liam, Chris...
Seven.
-Seven. Wait.
[ Bell dings ]
There you go! You go it right!
[ Cheering ]
-I know my Jonas Brothers!
-All right!
Well, joining Gabrielle's booth
is a DJ, songwriter,
record producer
who's new album,
"Father of Asahd" is out now.
Give it up for DJ Khaled!
[ Cheering ]
-Oh!
[ Cheering continues ]
-Come in my booth! Hey, baby!
-How you doing?
-Come on in!
-Wait, I want --
I want him in my booth.
-No.
-I would say it would've been
a problem about a year ago,
but I'm on Weight Watchers now,
so we good.
You know what I'm saying?
-You are tiny!
-Thank you.
-You're wasting away.
-They call me "Slim Jim"!
[ Laughter ]
-Next question is for Gabrielle.
-Okay.
-[ Whispering ] How you doing?
-I'm good.
[ Telephone rings ]
Hello?
-Gabrielle...
-Yes.
-Green Mamba...
-Uh-huh.
-...European asp,
and fer-de-lance
are all species of what animal?
-Snake.
-Judges.
[ Bell dings ]
Yes! The correct answer!
It was snake!
Joining Jimmy's booth,
animal expert Grant Kemmerer
and his 10-foot Burmese python
Sheila!
[ Cheering ]
Don't worry. Come on up.
Get right in there.
-Jimmy!
-Hey, buddy.
Nice to see you, pal.
-You okay?
-Hey, man.
-How you doing?
-Great. It's all good.
-Okay, next question.
-Oh, my gosh, are you joking me?
[ Laughter ]
Is that your hand?
-All right, the next question
is for Jimmy.
-Yes.
[ Telephone ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
-You want me to get it?
[ Cheering, laughter ]
[ Ringing continues ]
-[ Laughing ] Sorry, there was
a snake on the phone.
-Or are you just happy
to see me?
Jimmy!
Where in the body
is the coccyx bone.
The coccyx bone.
The coccyx!
-The butt.
-Coccyx bone.
-You think so?
-What part of the body...
-Uh...that'd be, uh --
that'd be in butt.
-[ Laughing ] In the butt?
In the butt! Judges?
[ Bell dings ]
Yes! It is the butt bone!
[ Cheering ]
Well, joining Gabrielle's booth
is the Grammy-winning musician
with a new album called
"Wah Gwaan?!"
This summer,
he's on tour with UB40,
make some room for Shaggy!
[ Cheering ]
-Yo!
-Hey!
-Shaggy!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Why am I getting --
What is going on?!
-All right! Hi, [indistinct].
-Wait, what is happening?!
-Lovely.
You get Khaled and Shaggy,
I have a 12-foot python
in my thing.
This is...rigged.
-Those are the rules
of the game.
-Look like you having fun.
-What?!
-Shaggy didn't get it wrong.
It wasn't him. Okay!
[ Laughter ]
Next question is for Gabrielle.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello.
-Yes.
Gabrielle,
what would take longer --
watching every episode
of "Game of Thrones"
or every Marvel superhero movie?
-Uh, uh, uh, uh...
So, "Game of Thrones" --
every episode --
that's eight seasons.
How many Marvel movies?
-I have no idea.
-I've only watched
"Black Panther".
[ Laughter ]
Uh...uh, uh...
-There's a lot.
-"Game of Thrones", right?
"Game of Thrones".
[ Slide whistle ]
-Answer?
-"Game of Thrones".
-"Game of Thrones" is correct!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheering ]
Joining Jimmy's booth, he plays
Grey Worm on "Game of Thrones"
and a recording artist
under the name
of Raleigh Ritchie
it's Jacob Anderson!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheering ]
Yo!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering continues ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Big fan.
Thank you for being
inside of my booth.
-This is --
-We got each other,
we got each other.
We have each other,
we have each other.
-Hold me. Yeah. All right.
[ Dial tone ]
-We all know what that means.
It's time for the final call.
-Okay.
-And the winner
of this next question...
-[ Chuckles ]
...gets to shove everyone else
from the mystery bench
into their opponent's booth.
So let's bring out the bench.
First, they're Olympic figure
skaters
and hosts of
"Wedding Cake Championship",
which premiers June 3rd at 10:00
p.m. on the Food Network.
Please welcome Johnny Weir
and Tara Lipinski!
[ Cheering ]
Plus...
-Hi, guys.
-Hi, buddy, how are you?
-...we've got two contortionists
from the Big Apple Circus,
Ellie and Ekaterina!
[ Cheering ]
-And from the
City of Brotherly Love,
it's the Phillie Phanatic!
-[ Chiming ]
-All right, final question...
-Who moved the door?!
Was that the snake?
-Who moved the door?
-...is for Jimmy.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-I can't even pick up the phone.
[ Ringing continues ]
-I'll let it ring.
We can wait.
[ Ringing continues ]
-Hello?
-Jimmy.
-Yes.
-Name three English words
that rhyme with pickle.
-Come on.
-I can't think of one.
-Sprinkle.
Sickle.
-Trickle.
-Sickle.
-Sickle, yes.
-Tickle.
-Two.
-Nickle.
-Nickle!
-Nickle, yes!
[ Bell dings ]
-Yay!
[ Cheering ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-That means Jimmy wins!
Let's see how many people we can
get into Gabrielle's booth. Oh!
-Open wide. [ Laughs ]
-Please, however you can fit
in there.
-Oh, God.
-Oh, of course.
[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God.
-I don't -- Oh, it's a foot.
-Are you okay? Can I help you?
Can you get in in any way?
Oh, my God, all right,
Johnny next to the
contortionist.
Go the Phanatic!
Phillie Phanatic,
can you get any --
-Phillie Phanatic,
just get your arm in there.
-That's it, right there.
There you go!
There's our winner!
My thanks to Gabrielle Union,
DJ Khaled,
Grant Kemmerer,
Jacob Anderson, Shaggy,
Johnny Weir, Tara Lipinski,
the Big Apple Circus,
and the Philadelphia Phillies.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break!
[ Cheering ]
[ Cheering continues ]